well we all know the strip is congested
with traffic now but it will be wide
open with Racers going speeds over 200
miles per hour come November's F1 race
it's expected every year here for the
next decade but a lot of questions
remain unanswered about the cost and
what construction will look like
annually eight news now reporter Ryan
Matthey took those questions right to F1
officials during a first look at the
starting line
it's a race to finish might sound a way
we've got Hamilton
before this race comes to town this has
been logistically complicated Friday a
first look at the F1 Paddock building on
Koval and Harmon this is where the teams
do all their magic the Terry Miller
project manager for the building in
circuit describes it as the heartbeat of
the internationally watched race a 300
000 square foot building equivalent to
the length of three football fields that
could one day look like this
[Music]
the ground level pit garages where the
anticipated 20 racing cars will be
assembled outside grandstands for 18 000
Spectators higher levels for the VIPs
and the rooftop with the 17 foot tall
beams that will one day hold this 28 000
square foot LED screen and right here is
where the race will both start and end
come November currently ongoing the
repaving on the Las Vegas Strip
officials tell us we won't see it at
that level in future years but it comes
at a price tag seemingly no one knows
for two months preparing the circuit
which runs through the Las Vegas Strip
has involved digging up six to ten
inches of asphalt leading to traffic
congestion Las Vegas Grand Prix CEO
Renee will knows well have you been in
that traffic with all the pavings I have
what was that like for you
that's frustrating but the project
manager says after this infrastructure
coming years we'll see much less as once
we go in and do this circuit that's a
density that can last with our typical
traffic that you and I drive every day
but still meets the criteria for an F1
race track and what about the cost we
really haven't finished modeling it yet
we are we're building the plane as we're
flying it we are activating the entire
town in a way that's never been done
before and we really think at the end of
the day and we hope that everyone will
agree with us
now the racetrack will surround 23 000
hotel rooms officials say in mid-october
they'll install traffic Bridges hundreds
of feet long around the circuit Clark
County Commissioners are also
anticipated to start the process of
allocating taxpayer dollars to that
project next week